مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفاع الناس كله والعالم كله كان مشغول
الاسبوع الماضي بفوز فريق اسمه جيرونا على
برشلونه جيرونا هو فريق من كتالونيا
وكانوا يعتبروه انه هو الفريق الفريند لي
الكتكوت هيك الصغير البسيط اللي دائما
بنفوز عليه اسبانيول وبرشلونه ماخذين
الشعبيه بمدينه برشلونه وباقل كتالونيا
عامه وهذا الفريق هو يعني على الهامش مش
كثير مهم بناخذ منه ثلاث نقاط دائما ومع
السلامه يعني ولكن جيرونا فاجا الجميع
جيرونا سعق الكل وانتصر على برشلونه 4
اثين هذا الفريق اللي كان قبل موسمين فقط
بدوري الدرجه الثانيه واللي كان عمي عاني
ليظل بدوري الدرجه الثانيه اليوم عم
بينتصر حقق انتصار و انتصار تل و انتصار
لحتى وصل انه تغلب على برشلونه على ارضيه
ملعب برشلونه ووسط جمهوره الناس كلها رغم
الاداء الايجابي لجون هذا الموسم كانت
مراهنه انه الجوله هي رح يسقط الجوله
الجايه رح يسقط اللي بعدها رح يسقط ولكن
اللي صار غير هيك تماما وكانت مباراه ريال
مدريد خدعه لانه بعد مباراه الريال الناس
كلها قالت هذا عمي فريق صغير بفوز على
الانديه الصغيره وبس يلعب ضد ريال مدريد
وبرشلونه ممكن رح يخسر وخلص والدليل
مباراه ريال مدريد ولكن مباراه ريال مدريد
نفسها ما كانت سهله على الريال رغم انه
النتيجه تبدو سهله ولكن المباراه نفسها
بتفاصيلها لم تكن سهله ابدا على ريال
مدريد جيرونا فريق محترم جدا لانه مش بس
فاز على برشلونه مثلا بالحظ ولا بهدف ولا
تكتل دفاعيا وراح اعتمد على المرتدات مثل
ما بتعمل كل فرق الدوري الاسباني من سنوات
لما بتلعب ضد برشلونه لا هو فريق استحوذ
وفريق فريق خرج بالكره تحت الضغط بشكل
رائع وفريق قدم مستوى خرافي واظهر برشلونه
متواضع لابعد الدرجات وبرشلونه نفسه ساعده
على الكلام هذا ولكن اداء جيرونا كان
خرافي الخروج بالكره التمريرات السريعه
زياده الايقاع كل ما اقتربنا من منطقه
الجزاء واستغلال المساحات مهاجمتها وتسجيل
الاهداف واستغلال الثغرات بدفاع برشلونه
كان قادر فريق ميشيل اللي هو مدرب جيرونا
انه يقدم مباراه ونموذج عالمي جدا خلى
البعض يتحمس ويشبهوا بفريق برشلونه بيب
2011 شو قصه جيرنا جيرونا هو فريق تاسس
عام 1930 يعني هو فريق جديد باعتبار اذا
بدك تقارنه بالفرق الكبيره هو فريق جديد
ما صار له زمان متاسس يعني ولم يحقق اي
انجاز كبير بتريقه هو بلش بدوري الدرجه
الخامسه بعدين الرابعه بعدين الثالثه ف
الثانيه فالاولى واليوم وصل للي وصل له
هذا الفريق على مدار السنوات كل الا لحد
2017 كان فريق متواضع مثل ما حكينا الناس
ما ما تهتم في كثير يعني واول مره تاهل
فيها للدوري الاسبانيا او لعب فيها
بالليجا كانت بموسم
20162017 بعد ما كان قريب جدا من التاهل
بالموسم اللي قبليه ولكن نجح بال 2017 انه
يوصل
لليجا قدم اداء ماشي حاله يعني سلك اموره
اول موسم ثاني موسم هبط لدوري الدرجه
الاولى مره ثانيه وظلوا بدوري الدرجه
الاولى موسمين لحد ما طلع بموسم 2021 2022
لحد ما بلش يقدم مستويات عظيمه جدا مثل ما
شفنا هذا الموسم هذا الفريق في ناس ما
بتعرف انه هو تابع للسيتي جروب السيتي
جروب اللي هي اصلا مالكه لنادي مانشستر
سيتي واللي تابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات اللي
موجود بالامارات واللي واللي طبعا مسؤول
عن ه المجموعه او صاحب او مالك ه المجموعه
هو الشيخ منصور بن زايد ال نهيان بعد
الاستحواذ على جزء من ج جيرنا طبعا صندوق
اللي هو السيتي جروب استحوذ على جزء من
جيرونا او على نسبه من من جيرونا بموسم
2017 او بسنه 2017 بشهر اوجس او اغسطس
وبعد ذلك بشهرين تقريبا جيرونا حقق مفاجاه
ونجح بانه ينتصر على ريال مدريد 2 واحد
وبعد ذلك بدا التخطيط للوصول الى ما وصل
اليه جيرنا اليوم واعتقد ها مجرد مرحله
نحو مرحله اكبر لهذا الفريق قد تكون
مشابهه لمرحله مانشستر سيتي بالدوري
الانجليزي البعض عم يشبه جيونا بليستر
ولكن وجهه نظري انه جيرونا مختلف عن ليستر
سيتي جيرونا هو مشروع مشروع متكامل من
البدايه وحتى الان ومستمر يعني ممكن تشبهه
مثلا بنيوكاسل ممكن تشبهه بالسيتي ولكن ما
بيشبه ليستر لستر كان بسموه و سيزون واندر
او انه هو كان يعني طلع فجاه هيك هبه وده
ب بموسم 2015 2016 بالدوري الانجليزي وحصد
الدوري الانجليزي بوقت كانت في بقيه الفرق
الى حد ما مش كثير قويه وهذا ليس تقليل من
انجاز ليستر ولكن ليستر ما كان عنده
المشروع اللي موجود عند جيرونا اليوم
جيرونا جاب لاعبين مكس ما بين لاعبين شوي
كبار بالعمر عم تحكي عن 28 27 سنه صرف
بسوق الانتقالات الاخير تقريبا 22 مليون
يورو وباع لاعبين بقيمه 17 مليون يورو
وفقا لموقع ترانسفير ماركت نوع باللاعبين
جاب اريك جارسيا من برشلونه كلاعب عنده
خبره لاعب بالدوري الانجليزي لاعب بالدوري
الاسباني قادر انه يقود خط الدفاع نعم هو
ما كان بالكواليس تي ومع برشلونه ولكن بظل
بالنسبه لجينا هو اضافه كثير كبيره جاب
المهاجم الاوكراني الضخم اللي شفناه ايضا
جاب عدد من اللاعبين المميزين واستغنى
بالمقابل عن بعض اللاعبين مثل اوريول
روميو اللي راح على برشلونه وطبعا جمهور
برشلونه لسان حاله بيقول يا ريت ما راح
يعني لانه الفريق ما استفاد منه بشيء من
لما اجا ولكن رحيل اوريول روميو كمان دخل
مردود للنادي هو جاي على سبيل الاعاره
طبعا مش جاي بصفقه بيع والفريق قدر انه
يضبط اموره الماليه ويعمل تشكيله حلوه جدا
من لاعبين ما حدا بيعرفهم حرفيا يعني
باستثناء ربما جوتيريز اللي كان لاعب مع
ريال مدريد او طالع من اكاديميه ريال
مدريد واريك جارسيا وجازان جا اللي هو
الحارس اعتقد انه بقيه ال لاعبين مش
معروفين ابدا بالنسبه لجماهير كره القدم
هذول اللاعبين اللي مش معروفين جدا كان
معهم مدرب ايضا مش معروف مدرب جيونا اسمه
ميشيل درب هويسكا ودرب رايو فايكانو ميشيل
ما عنده اسم ولكن ميشيل جاي بفكر فكر
مشابه لفكر السيتي جروب مشابه لطريقه
اللعب اللي السيتي جروب حابب انه يشوفها
برونا اسلوب الاستحواذ اسلوب لعب الكره
على الارض التيكي تاكا مع انه جوارديولا
بكتابه ما بحب تسميه تيكي تاكا ولكن هي
المتعارف عليها هيك هيك التسميه يعني اللي
هو لعب الكرات على الارض والتدرج نحو
المرمى يعني باختصار والبوز شن او
الاستحواذ وللمفارقة
نا ونجحوا انهم يطبقوه هذا الموسم بافضل
طريقه ممكنه ليخلق منظومه جميله جدا
منظومه فيها مكس بين لاعبين مثل ايضا
نسينا ديلي بليند بالمناسبه مثل ديلي
بليند لاعب الخبره ومثل اريك جارش لاعب
الخبره وفيها ايضا لاعبين شباب صغار
قادرين انهم يقدموا مستويات كبيره ويعطوا
عطاءات وتضحيات داخل ارضيه الملعب اللي
شفناه لحد الان من جرونا هو معجزه بكل
المقاييس معجزه ما حدا كان متخيلها الا
القائمين على نادي جيره الا اللي كانوا عم
خططوا لهي المرحله ومدرب الفريق ميشيل قبل
مباراه برشلونه قال اذا انتصرنا على
برشلونه فينا نقول انه نحن دخلنا ب
دايمنشن جديد او ببعد جديد بالنسبه لهذا
الفريق وهذا فعلا اللي حدث جيرون الان صار
محط نظر العالم اكيد اي فريق رح يلعب ضده
رح يحسب له حساب بعد مباراه برشلونه هذا
لا يعني انه هو رح يحصل رقم لقب الدوري او
رح يفوز باللقب قد يسقط في قادم الاسابيع
قد يستمر بالمنافسه ولكن بنهايه الامر ما
حققه لحد الان هو شيء تاريخي سيبقى في
الذاكره لفتره طويله وخلينا نشوف كيف رح
يصير تطور هذا النادي مع الوقت ولوين راح
يوصل بالمواسم المقبله لحد الان الشيء
الوحيد اللي فينا نقوله برافو جيرونا
وبرافو سيتي هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم
بعد الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
تكونوا بالف
خير